[Música]
esta es la costa norte de antrim parte
de la nueva frontera comercial entre el
reino unido y la unión europea
víctor chesnutt preside una granja de
200 hectáreas y representa a 24 mil
agricultores de irlanda del norte
detrás de mi estado legal república de
irlanda y de este lado cuando el día
está despejado se puede ver escocia
escocia es por supuesto parte de gran
bretaña nuestra región tiene 18 millones
de habitantes y producimos suficiente
comida para alimentar a 10 millones así
que tenemos que exportar y si hay un
costo extra para gran bretaña europa es
un costo que no podemos absorber
víctor es dueño de 400 vacas la carne
que produce se vende en el resto del
reino unido pero su leche es procesada
en la república de irlanda y exportada a
gran bretaña como queso a partir de
enero los productos de origen animal
podrían requerir un certificado de
exportación
y esta leche se va a cada dos días si se
necesita un certificado de salud no es
práctico traer a un veterinario de la
granja cada dos días no podemos
permitírnoslo solo esperamos que se
llegue a algún tipo de acuerdo sin cargo
extra de lo contrario es el fin de la
producción de leche en irlanda del norte
en el puerto de belfast medio millón de
camiones descargan sus mercancías cada
año después de cruzar el mar de irlanda
por el momento las formalidades son
insignificantes pero eso podría cambiar
muy pronto a partir de enero se sentirá
el verdadero impacto del presi
irlanda del norte seguirá bajo el
control de la unión europea y la
frontera europea será de hecho entre
gran bretaña e irlanda del norte este es
el nuevo puesto de control en el puerto
de belfast y está lejos de ser el
checkpoint charlie la infraestructura de
recepción aún no ha sido construida pero
después de este punto cualquier producto
de origen animal tendrá que ir
acompañado de un certificado de salud
álex por sus efectos es hasta saint un
certificado sanitario de exportación es
un certificado firmado por un
veterinario que tendrá que tener todos
los alimentos de origen animal como
carne leche y huevos cuando crucen la
frontera de la unión europea a partir
del primero de enero
market brawn dirige un delicatessen en
belfast durante las vacaciones su
producto más vendido es el estilo tone
colston based el llamado rey de los
quesos ingleses este queso me cuesta 60
libras ahora mismo a partir del primero
de enero
si puedo conseguirlo me costará 120
libras
al doble de precio debido a los
controles sanitarios es probable que él
stilton tenga menos éxito pensé que
cuando salíamos de europa tendríamos
problemas para encontrar quesos europeos
pero en realidad es lo contrario son los
quesos ingleses escoceses y galeses los
que van a hacer el problema las grandes
cadenas de supermercados incluidas en
sever bis han advertido que muchos
productos de consumo diario podrían no
estar disponibles en irlanda del norte
después del primero de enero algunas
empresas podrían incluso decidir
retirarse de un mercado de irlanda del
norte- demasiado costosos
para que invertir en irlanda del norte
si hay que rellenar formularios cuando
se envían bienes y servicios para que
mantener un vínculo con gran bretaña si
cuesta caro es importante saber que el
mercado de irlanda del norte depende en
gran medida del mercado británico
en este almacén en las afueras de
belfast se clasifican los paquetes de
todo el reino unido a partir de enero
esos mismos productos que vayan a
irlanda del norte necesitarán una
declaración de aduana incluso en el
marco de un acuerdo de libre comercio
entre el reino unido y la unión europea
actualmente recibimos 2000 paquetes
diarios de gran bretaña para ser
entregados en irlanda del norte a partir
del primero de enero tendremos que tener
una declaración de aduanas para cada
producto lo que va a tener un gran
impacto en la cadena de distribución
lo único seguro del preside es que habrá
una avalancha de problemas
administrativos sin embargo a los
políticos se les había alertado sobre el
impacto del protocolo de irlanda del
norte por un estudio del profesor
decirlo
irlanda del norte se encuentra en un
rincón de europa con las ventajas de
permanecer en la zona aduanera de la
unión europea pero también con grandes
desventajas especialmente para una
economía ya frágil
con una frontera comercial en el mar de
irlanda es inaceptable para quienes
apoyan que irlanda del norte sea parte
del reino unido como este ex líder del
partido unionista de ulster
para salvar su propio pellejo en
inglaterra no dudó en echarlos a los
leones somos las víctimas del éxito de 6
funcionarios electos o empresarios
los responsables de earl a
del norte sueñan con una sola cosa un
acuerdo que pueda salvarlos de una caída
en lo desconocido el primero de enero